should i keep going i got a great but uh
you know heart-wrenching question from
one of my readers on youtube india food
you know love you guys who wrote in to
say hi evan i'm working full-time and
operate a grocery store with my wife
recently made an agreement to buy a
quiznos franchise now i'm taking
training and found that it's not easy to
manage the quiznos and found that it's
not making money it will break even if
sales increase without paying me i'm
struggling to decide what to do in this
situation please suggest
you know i really feel for you
it's a situation that i hate seeing
and it underlines how
hard it is to run a business it's hard
running any business is hard you think
okay i'm going to get a franchise it's
all laid out for me it's super easy and
you know no problems but it's still hard
it may be a little bit easier running a
franchise but it's still hard it's a lot
of work and there's no guarantee that's
going to work out
and i could give you
ideas strategies techniques to help you
grow this but you have to answer one
question first and like any important
question you have to make the decision
with your heart
and it's really answering do you love
this business
are you passionate about this quiznos
franchise because it sounds to me like
you got into it just to make money and
lots of entrepreneurs do that right lots
of people start a business because they
think hey i can make a lot of money some
easy money just sitting there so i'm
gonna i'm gonna start it and that's why
so many entrepreneurs fail because
they're in it just for the money and if
you're in it just for the money you
never make money if you look at the most
successful entrepreneurs you look at why
they started their business they didn't
do it to make lots of money they made a
lot of money as a result i'm not saying
you're doing a charity this isn't
charity work here you're here to make
money but it's not the main reason to do
anything if that's your main reason then
stop and go do something else so are you
passionate about this i don't know you
that well i don't know you really that
much at all but what i got from your
email
was that you did this business just
trying to make some money it's not
working out you don't know what to do
i don't feel any passion for what you're
doing right now i don't feel any passion
or love for this quizno's franchise and
it kind of sounds like you regret making
that decision what i know is that you
can't do anything great
in your life you can't really be a happy
person in your life if you're not doing
things that make you come alive if
you're not doing things that you are
deeply passionate about and so if the
quiz knows franchise if that's not
bringing you love and passion
then you got to let it go sell it
drop it don't think about the money you
invested don't think about the time you
put into this don't think about oh this
is going to be seen as a failure
what's worse would be continuing on
not taking a salary putting more time
and effort into it and continually being
more and more dissatisfied that you're
not doing something that you're getting
results from
and it takes courage to cut to cut
something off it takes courage to have
made a bet on something and it doesn't
work and then say you know what i can't
keep going that takes guts
and it sounds like it's the right call
for you i'd set aside the lists set
aside the logical reasons to do it set
aside all the energy you've already
invested into it and really
sit back
and try to listen to your heart
and answer the question
do you love
this business or not
and if it's not
then let it go and move on to something
that you are passionate about
believe for those of you watching like
this video you can subscribe to the
channel means a lot to me thank you so
much i'll see you soon